do you think that you have an invisible
string with wellie your husband here's
the deal so I think the Invisible String
Theory is hanging by a thread that's
what I think I I I love love don't get
me wrong I I want to believe in
soulmates and I do I do believe that
your souls can match with people but the
Invisible String Theory makes me feel
like you don't have to do any work to
get it that love is just going to find
you because it's predestined so you can
sit at home and wait for that person to
find you easy love does not work like
like that okay you have to get out of
the house you have to say hi to people
you have to be interesting you have to
be interested you have to go and get
love it you have to work for it if you
sit at home trust me it's not finding
you